voilà une polémique qui risque une
nouvelle fois de faire beaucoup parler
celui du taux d'alcoolémie autorisé au
volant
tolérance zéro pour l'alcool au volant
sur la route justement boire ou conduire
il va bientôt falloir vraiment choisir
si on sait aujourd'hui que le taux
autorisé d'alcoolémie au volant est de
0,5 gramme par litre de sang
cette autorisation pourrait rapidement
disparaître et laisser place à une
tolérance zéro
pourtant c'est tolérance française ne
permet de boire qu'un ou deux verres
d'alcool avant de prendre la route
une marge qui ne semble pas si démesuré
mais ce n'est visiblement pas l'avis du
ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume qui a annoncé lors de
l'émission le grand rendez vous que
cette tolérance pourrait totalement
disparaître dans les mois à venir je
pense que lorsqu'on conduit on ne doit
pas boire si ce n'est pas la première
fois que ce débat est posé sur la table
il est certain que ce sujet brûlant à
gaz de nombreux français entre la baisse
des limitations de vitesse la croissance
des contrôles radars ou la montée des
sanctions contre les automobilistes de
nombreux citoyens commencent à s'agacer
80 on n'avance pas 4 selon la sécurité
routière près d'un tiers des accidents
de la route seraient directement liés à
une trop grande consommation d'alcool
il a près de 2000 personnes qui ont
encore l'année dernière perdu la vie
dans un accident de la route impliquant
un conducteur alcoolisé
alors selon vous faut-il interdire
totalement l'alcool au volant alors
faut-il interdire totalement la colle
que l'on vous pose la question ça tout
le monde a un avis là dessus alors moi
je vais me tourner vers les noms déjà
géraldine vous dit non
alors oui l'alcool est dangereux oui
l'alcool dessus et oui l'alcool fait des
ravages chez les jeunes et pas que mais
ça évidemment il s'agit pas du tout ici
de défendre l'alcool au volant
en revanche moi je pense que le ministre
de l'agriculture qui a annoncé sa et
complètement à côté de la plaque
d'abord il a changé d'avis sur la
question il avait de départ oui on peut
voir s'aggrave le vin c'est pas
dangereux
maintenant il dit ça il ferait mieux de
s'occuper du sort des agriculteurs et
leurs maris par des jours à son sujet
magot tulle ac aurait bon c'est pas
démago c'est lui qui les magrets et pour
moi en fait c'est un faux problème et il
connaît pas son sujet pourquoi quand on
se met un spray buccal par exemple dans
la bouche
eh ben on est à 0 2 non oui et les bus
par exemple ils peuvent pas démarrer à
la ratp parce qu'il ya une sorte de
radar qui montre que justement ils sont
trop alcoolisés on n'est pas le colisée
quand on a un spray buccal n'est ce pas
donc ça veut dire que c'est juste
grotesque et qu'en fait il connaît pas
les règles et que donc je pense qu'il
faut juste éduquer les gens il faut leur
apprendre et que inverse 0,2 et je pense
qu'un verre ça va ya pas mort
alors eric naulleau vous dites oui il
faut interdire totalement d'accord
d'abord un il faut en finir avec la
complaisance envers l'alcool en france
parce que voilà la drogue tout le monde
est vent debout l'alcool tout nous
tolèrent oui voilà vers 1000 morts il
mort il faut en finir avec ces
spécialités dont c'est la spécialité
c'est un oui ou un non mais nous on
n'est jamais dans louis dans le nom on
est dans le milieu
d'ailleurs on peut boire mais un peu à
sortons de cette culture de l'ambiguïté
pas d'alcool au volant ça se pratique
dans beaucoup de pays
ça marche très bien et ça donne
d'excellents résultats sur la
moralisation jean-michel du rupture si
son as mois pour ceux qui dépassent la
limite qui est déjà limite quand même
assez sévère et ça m'étonne pas me
répond c'est une mesure pour une
lentille sinon mesures anti populaires
parce qu'on aura les moyens de changer
ses habitudes voire d'en sortir
c'est ce qu'ont argent non il est pauvre
tous les billets assis les il ya des
gens qui peuvent tourner à taxer tous
les soirs yapen jean-dominique travail
tombe les moyens de préparer le soir en
corse en baisse mais tu peux quand quand
tu sors à plusieurs effectivement il y
en a un c'est ce que celui qu'on appelle
le fameux le sam alors qu'ils ne le vous
qui ne boit pas les trois autos les 4
août le boivent peu importe assurée
alors ya le sa voiture alors je vous dis
chez vous il ya le sam celui qui ne voit
pas il ya le dock celui qui voit ses
confrères elle existe déjà en roumanie
en bulgarie en hongrie en république
tchèque en slovaquie et ça fonctionne
très très bien et on est même au dessus
de la pologne l'estonie la suède la
finlande qui sont à 0 2 nous on est
encore à 0,5 et pardon moi je pense que
non seulement il faut il faut faire un
degré zéro vraiment interdire
complètement mais par ailleurs moi je
pense qu'il faut faire comme les anglais
et les anglais sont au dessus de nous il
soit 0,8 mais pas mais ils ont moins
d'accidents que nous pourquoi parce que
les sanctions elles sont colossales
c'est à dire que la sanction tu prends
25000 base assez bien
superbe arrive en angleterre raymond qui
est chauffeur routier c'est quand même
voilà qu'ils trouvent leurs livreurs
belges suisses alors en mangez moi j'ai
changé mais comportant ce qu'au début ça
m'arrivait de boire 3 4 verres et je
prenais quand même la route et
maintenant je me dis que deux verres
c'est pour ça que je pense que la loi
aujourd'hui à 0,5
elle est bien faite parce que deux
verres inverse de vertu peut reprendre
la route est encore bien tes pattes et
pas celui qu on aperçoit la personne est
tuée alors je lui parlais je parlais du
patrimoine il faut sauver le patrimoine
le vin fait partie du patrimoine où le
vin c'est des millions de petits bandits
qui peut voir déclamation voulait sauver
des immeubles et ouais mais tu vois
c'est tout ajoute à la légende ça et là
vous vous êtes en train de me sortir
nous c'est facile on a à paris on prend
hubert empruntera m'en prends le mettez
le feu de médias il s'agit pas de jeu
rejoint valérie sur les sanctions parce
que quelqu'un qui a été touché par la
mort au volant ce de quelqu'un il peut
pas entendre ce que je suis en train de
dire donc les sanctions c'est 0,5 par
contre si tu es au dessus de 0,5 et a
fait le malin a par contre eu lieu car
sénat jean marc soboth les
téléspectateurs vers si oui à 58% non à
40 bon c'est assez mitigé